i cannot be more excited to have on this
show right now calling in
i love this man's work what he does on
better call saul
and breaking bad is just been amazing he
is jonathan banks
the man who plays mike ermantrout right
here on the rich eisen show how are you
sir
how are you sir i'm good thank you very
much better for talking to you
that's how i am doing um so
who are you who are you channeling from
mike ermantrout
jonathan who are you channeling for this
character well
before we get into that i mean you're
talking about if i may
since i may please you're talking about
all these motor geniuses
all these great athletes yes you know
and
you go through it all the time now i've
been watching the local news
and they've these kids that have not had
a chance to graduate they're
highlighting
the soccer teams and the
field hockey teams and even wonderful
kids
and and talented kids
now i would really like to see them i
want them
i want them to spotlight and bring on
all the guys that were seniors that were
still playing on the junior varsity
i'd like to see some some of the kids
that are having to sling hamburgers just
to get through school i'd like to
highlight some of these people
okay you know that's that's my
that's my pet tea for the day and that
your pet pee for the day is
that that people who are not getting the
spotlight
uh but the shaft in in what's going on
in the world
should get the spotlight yeah well you
know i mean just the guys even if
they're not getting the shaft
the women and the men that are in the
trenches just slugging along
and it and it starts it starts in high
school it starts before high school
um yeah yeah anyway
how do i channel mike no it's okay hold
on a second
hold on a second hold on so uh before we
before we return there then
so did you did you play sports in high
school did you try
at some point to to get into sports or
in any way shape or form yeah
i mean i play that's how i could yes i i
played a lot of sports very poorly
okay um i could sit on a on a bench in
baseball and
and and i had a coach that uh when i
said i wanted to try out for the junior
class
play yes he said you know and all i was
doing was sitting on a bench
i mean and i and he said to me thanks he
said you know
all actors and come on i thought
yes i tell you so
and at my 40th reunion
they have you fill out a thing about who
inspired you yes
and so i put down i said you know i'll
never forget
coach sessom's words and and i really do
hope that miserable
was still alive to read it you know so
when you say
when i ask who are you channeling mike
ermantrout are you channeling yourself
at any point jonathan
well you know i mean that no because
that would make it you know that'll make
it too grandiose most of the fights i've
ever been in in my life i've gotten
kicked out we're on live we're on live
television and radio right now oh okay
well there you go um and
so the poop kicked out of me thank you
very much okay
um um no you know i mean mike
we all want to be mike armatrout he gets
things done he survives
uh i don't know yeah
who do i channel i don't know who i
channel um
you stay alive long enough i guess you
see a lot of things
and i do have friends
that that had to do things that i didn't
do
you know i was part of that that vietnam
generation that was a lot of guys were
fodder
and very some very close friends of mine
who are still friends of this day
um they they went and
um they carried my i'm going to
bleep it out i'm sorry because it's just
the way i do no i know
whether i agree with that war i don't my
friends had to carry my
and you know i went off to university
um and some of those guys who were my
dear friends i still
uh yeah i
there's a there's a part of them that's
in my my german trout
jonathan banks here on the rich eisen
show live on
nbcsn siriusxm and youtube.com
rich eisenshow so uh we had giancarlo
esposito on the show
a couple of times and he said there were
some scenes
when he would read it on the page he
knew it would be intense for him to
actually act out and then when he did
act
out he needed some time uh after it's
all over have you had
similar scenes like that either in
breaking bad or better call saul
jonathan well you know i don't mean to
be a smart alec but it's
um i let go of things pretty quick
uh at least i think i do
um there's no way you know when i there
there's a one scene where i talk about
causing the death of my son
that you don't either
you just don't tap into that and then
just walk away from it right
yeah yeah no and john carla let me tell
you john carlo
is is the antithesis of gus
john carlo is so full of life and
ebullient and exuberant
having a good time
he's the best he is i love having him on
the show
and he you know he and i talk about love
of the yankees together because he's
he's from there
do you have a favorite baseball team
football team jonathan
dude i grew up in washington d.c
no what are you doing in my my team who
were the senators
and a real heartbreaker when there were
eight teams in the american eight teams
in the national right yeah the
senators were perennial sellers dwellers
so they finally they finish in second
place
around what was it 1960 61 something
like that
yes and and calvin griffith sells them
to minnesota
my i was a kid my heart was just broken
and it was two years later they won the
pennant with
camilo pasquale at that short stop zoro
versailles with premier pitcher earl
batty behind the plate
it was the same team so
yeah when i was glad in in last year
the miracle the miracle no doubt
that they win the world series they'll
always be the percentages to me no
matter what they call them
right the nationals expos or whatever so
you were invested in that watching that
last year the nationals
how could you not be he was amazing
could you not be so who's your player
who's your player growing up then
jonathan i mean who was you who
who's who's your favorite athlete i
guess of all time
um you know i saw harman killebrook play
his rookie game
at the old dc stadium at griffith
stadium
and you know i just kind of followed
harman keller throughout it
i got to tell you though brooks uh
brooks robinson
you know i've played golf with him
before and every time i see him
i just you know i want to like throw a
ball on the ground and watch him scoop
it up no matter how old he is you want
to talk about great human beings too
that guy is a human being of all human
beings that guy i love brooks robinson
it's a good he's a good guy man i mean
and just uh one of the all-time best
i've got jonathan banks here uh on the
rich eisen show
so uh i just want to go a little bit
down your your filmography
um what was it like on the set of
airplane back in 1980
jonathan well for me i mean you know
bobby hayes is one of my dear friends
but we didn't become
friends on that film um it was in 1988
when i met my wife in spain and we were
doing a film in spain but what was it
like on that set
um you know i went in to do a job and i
just
kind of showed up and i participated in
the silliness and
walked away but uh you know that's the
old kentucky fried theater that was over
on pico boulevard oh yeah
where those guys came from yeah zuckers
and
mgm yeah and and uh lloyd bridges
was in the summer scenes with you right
yeah and
robert stack i got to tell you that
those guys it was so
it was so much fun to see them and and
they were having a good time
they were cutting up and they were
having a good time and
you know robert stack had a drool sense
of humor anyway but it was
yeah it was fun i was young it was fun i
know
i've see i see some of the photographs
from it and obviously the movie uh
is one of my all-time favorites and then
a couple of years later you you were
involved in two films with eddie murphy
uh 48 hours and nick nolte uh that was a
a quick cup of coffee for your character
spoiler alert and then uh
beverly hills cop where you're the
individual who i guess technically
wrecked the buffet at the harrow club
correct jonathan i did and but i but i
shot his i shot his friend in the head
jimmy russo
and mikey and jimmy jeremy's a great guy
and jimmy and i are friends
um you know it was one of those things
too where jimmy wanted to get into it
i'm slapping him in the hall and i'm
going up jimmy we can't eat i know he's
slapping me slightly fight me you know i
want
it's acting jimmy stop it i know so did
you did you do your
did you actually do your own stunt to go
through the table at the harrow club
jonathan um louis elias was
my stunt guy for years i've always
passed away now but
um i do the first lift and i wasn't
doing it clean it up
okay and so louie comes in and it's it's
a
it's a very smooth cut that you go
through there but no that the one that
they used is
louie going across the table okay gotta
check on that that that's uh
i'll tell you what he was a player uh
just on sports talk and lilly was a i
think an all-american at ucla in 1953 or
54
and then played in canada after that
i think i'm right about that man oh man
jonathan banks ear on the rich eisen
show better call saul
um so the final season do you have any
idea
uh when when you might get back to work
at all right now
on that jonathan is there a script
anywhere that you no you know i haven't
called anybody either
because it's one of those things where
you know i imagine these lawyers in
these studios are trying to figure out
how we get them back in and how we do it
and i would think that for them i'm a
liability because i'm 73 years old
now i'm in relatively decent shape but
at the same time
you know if if the statistic at the
statistics are correct
it might be rolling the dice to send me
back in there
well i'll tell you what you're great at
it jonathan and i just hope you stay
safe stay at home and i love what you're
doing in this show
and um and i know we we met briefly at
uh
uh charity golf tournament uh here in
los angeles for the american red cross
it was good to see you then and i hope
to see you again soon
thank you sir right back at you yeah
right back at you that's jonathan banks
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here